bonjour monsieur
nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir ici dans le cadre de
cette mission qui est celle donc du
développement
mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène verte voilà on va
vous écouter avec passion nous donc mes
chers collègues alors je vais d'abord
excuser le président de notre mission
qui pour des raisons que l'on peut
connaître qui sont celles de difficultés
de transport aujourd'hui elle est
obligée de prendre un départ plutôt que
prévu pour pouvoir rentrer chez lui
alors nous reprenons les travaux de
notre mission d'information sur le
développement d'une FIA de biocarburant
qui a environ synthétique durable
hydrogène vert vous recevant maintenant
le groupe stelantis donc qui est
représenté ici par Monsieur Jean-Luc
Brossard
vice-président en charge de la recherche
automobile et de l'ingénierie avancée et
par Monsieur Jean-Pascal Viat déléguer
en charge des affaires publiques pour la
France Monsieur Brossard vous le
superviser ainsi des questions relatives
aux technologies vertes à l'énergie et à
l'Analyse de Cycle du cycle de vie
vous représentez le groupe stellantis au
sein de l'association hydrogène Europe
et vous êtes coordinateur pour la PFA
que nous venons donc de visionner que
vous êtes croisés des programmes
concernant les véhicules à faible
empreinte environnementale et à
l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie vous avez
enfin été tout récemment désigné
président du Comité des constructeurs
français de automobile
élu c'est quand même mieux merci pour
vous je rappelle que cette réunion est
captée est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat sur lequel elle
pourra ensuite être consultée en vidéo
et à la demande je remercie le groupe
stellantise d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et je n'ai pas cité monsieur
mais si je vous ai cité aussi je veux je
suis né qu'à un autre groupe français
que nous avons également sollicité à
refuser de venir s'exprimer très
clairement très simplement devant cette
mission et nous le regrettons le plus
vivant
bien sûr messieurs notre mission
d'information comprend des membres issus
de différentes commissions qui
représentent l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat le développement des
filières de biocarburant de carburant
synthétique durable et d'hydrogène vert
représente un enjeu important pour
permettre à la France et à l'Union
européenne data d'objectifs de
neutralité carbone en 2050 mais aussi
pour notre souveraineté et la
compétitivité de notre économie la fin
de la commercialisation des véhicules
légers fonctionnant avec un moteur
thermique à compter de 2035 a été au
centre des discussions européennes
récentes l'Allemagne ayant notamment
plaidé au cours de la dernière ligne
droite en faveur des carburants
synthétiques durables quant aux
objectifs des missions pour les poids
lourds les discussions ont commencé plus
tardivement et se poursuivent encore
actuellement
donc vous aborderez certainement les
enjeux du basculement vers l'électricité
pour les véhicules légers nous sommes
nombreux à nous interroger sur les
impacts de cette mesure tant pour la
filière automobile dans son ensemble que
pour les usagers nous nous interrogeons
également sur les modalités de la
transition vers ce nouveau paradigme est
sur les amoniations éventuelles du cadre
européen qui pourrait intervenir à
l'occasion de la clause de revoyure
prévue elle en 2026
nous avons compris par ailleurs que
l'électricité ne permettrait pas de
couvrir tous les besoins d'affiliaire
automobile et que le recours à d'autres
types de carburants ou de vecteurs
énergétiques serait donc nécessaire pour
certains types de véhicules ou d'autres
usages
Carlos navares de président directeur
général de stéatisme à lui-même tenu des
propos critiques sur le tout électrique
puisqu'il a encore appelé fin février à
sortir du dogme de l'électricité vous
nous direz comment votre groupe affine
sa stratégie en prenant en compte
l'ensemble des marchés mondiaux car si
la fin de la commercialisation de
véhicule particulier un moteur thermique
se confirme en Europe à compter 2035 un
groupe comme le vôtre ne peut pas
ignorer les autres marchés mondiaux
notre rapporteur monsieur Vincent
apocanella vous a adressé un
questionnaire qui peut vous servir de
guide mais aussi vous pouvez introduire
votre propos bien évidemment comme vous
le souhaitez je passe ensuite la parole
à notre rapporteur puis à l'ensemble de
mes collègues afin qu'ils puissent vous
relancer et vous poser un certain nombre
de questions tout ceci se faisant dans
la plus grande simplicité amitié
convivialité et puis efficacité vous
avez la parole monsieur
merci beaucoup pour cette introduction
et pour le contexte bien déployé
donc au niveau du groupe silentis je
vais reprendre le fil directeur donc
proposé par le rapporteur sachant qu'il
aborde en fait l'ensemble des points le
premier point est que stellantis c'est
un groupe qui s'est engagé dans une
ambition forte en fait sur la réduction
d'empreintes environnementales au sens
large et pour cela
a présenté en fait un plan qui s'appelle
dark for what 2030 un plan qui a comme
objectif en fait de s'inscrire dans une
neutralité carbone net0 en 2038 en 2038
c'est bientôt c'est dans 15 ans
exactement mais à l'échelle de
l'industrie automobile c'est quelque
chose de très très ambitieux pour cela
on a pris la décision et carlosavares se
dit depuis sous longtemps en fait et les
orientations stratégiques ont été prises
depuis 2014 c'est-à-dire que le gros un
gros automobile est une industrie à
temps long et on n'a pas attendu en fait
pour décider en fait la transition
transition énergétique et écologique
nécessaire en fait dans le secteur
automobile et donc on a des ambitions en
fait en Europe en 2030 de ne plus vendre
que 100% en fait de nos véhicules seront
véhicules électriques quand je dis
véhicule électrique il y a deux types de
véhicules électriques il faut ces
véhicules électriques à batterie ou
véhiculer électrique à pile à
combustible c'est à dire à hydrogène et
donc c'est notre objectif en Europe 100%
aux États-Unis 50% de novembre seront à
l'horizon 2030 seront seront également
électriques et donc ceci s'accompagne en
fait par une forte implant gamme qui
prend en compte en fait cette cette
décision et on peut annoncer 60 modèles
nouveaux électriques en 2030 et vous en
avez déjà beaucoup je sais pas si vous
avez vu les gammes faites du groupe
telantis c'était l'antenne que c'était
lentilles c'est un groupe à 14 marques
et vous retrouvez des 208 électriques
des 2008 électriques des DS3 électrique
qui tendent ça s'appelle vous retrouver
des Fiat 500 électrique un certain
nombre de modèles qui sont déjà proposés
et cette année nous lancerons 308 3008
5008 donc dans des versions fortement
électrifiées
donc pour nous quelle est la perspective
de vente et l'arrêt des moteurs
thermiques en 2035 je voudrais préciser
c'est que dans vos discours vous avez
précisé probablement une action sur les
émissions de carbone mais la neutralité
des émissions et l'objectif
environnemental qu'on a ce n'est pas que
le carbone et ce n'est pas que que le
sujet le choix de passer à des véhicules
électriques a été guidée également par
la notion de qualité de l'air c'est à
dire que en local on le voit dans nos
cités et bientôt plus de 70 80% de nos
concitoyens vivront dans des zones
proches des villes
la qualité de l'air est fondamentale et
la qualité de l'air si vous voulez zéro
émission zéro Nox il y a pas 36
solutions il faut avoir un véhicule
électrique et seuls les véhicules
électriques à batterie et les véhicules
électriques à hydrogène le permettent et
c'est ça qui est important donc la
trajectoire est déjà donnée si on prend
en plus la norme en fait telle qu'elle
est cataly convenu en Europe donc vous
savez que les normes café qu'on appelle
donc sur le CO2
demande en fait pour les véhicules
particuliers une baisse de 55% des
émissions de CO2 entre 2030 et 2021 pour
les véhicules utilitaires légers une
baisse de 50% entre 2030 et 2021 et pour
les véhicules lourds donc les camions en
particulier une baisse de 45% entre 2030
et 2019 simplement cet objectif là sans
parler de l'objectif 2035 impose une
très très forte électrification de nos
gammes
c'est à dire que vous allez pour
respecter en fait un -55% en 2030 ça
demandera dans les marchés européens
plus de 70% de véhicules capables de
rouler zéro émission
et donc quand on a 70% des ventes qui
sont qui sont passés à l'électrique on
s'aperçoit que c'est les ventes en fait
sont déjà sont déjà fortement engagés
et donc ça veut dire que le reste a
produit en véhicule autre que véhicule
électrique est faible et donc il faut
raisonner par les usages c'est ça qui
est fondamental c'est raisonné par les
usages quels sont les usages on sait que
nos concitoyens ou le majoritairement
moins de X km mais très faiblement
kilomètre donc tous les jours et donc on
peut besoin forcément de d'usage
forcément intensifs ou de longues
distances et donc le véhicule électrique
fait la part du travail il n'y a pas de
problème pour le véhicule léger il y a
le travail est faisable un véhicule
électrique à condition d'avoir deux
paramètres d'un écosystème qui sont
importants le premier c'est que si on
veut parler de mobilité des carbonées
faut que l'énergie soit décarbonée et
une énergie décarbonée c'est à dire dans
un premier temps de l'électricité des
carbonées en par chance en France on est
bien placé sur sur ce point-là grâce à
l'énergie nucléaire qui qui quand même
majoritairement produite dans nos
contrées mais il faut avoir de l'énergie
décarbonée quel que soit les types
d'énergie nergie ou de vecteurs
énergétiques parce que dans le cas de
l'hydrogène ou dans le cas d'un
carburant synthétique on parlera de
vecteurs énergétique
et ensuite une fois qu'on a des de
l'énergie décarbonée une fois qu'on a
des
usages et des objets qui répondent aux
usages et c'est ce que je vous ai dit
rien que pour un groupe comme c'est
lentis en Europe plus de 60 modèles
électriques à proposer à nos clients et
si on rajoute les mêmes pourcentages
pour Volkswagen Renault et autres vous
allez retrouver des objectifs avec 200
300 modèles donc il y aura l'embarras du
choix entre guillemets pour ceux qui
tourneront vers la mobilité électrique
il sera important de trouver les
infrastructures nécessaires à sécuriser
ses usages et donc le point fondamental
c'est d'accompagner aussi par des
infrastructures et donc le premier à la
première ambition de du groupe sémantis
c'est d'accompagner une mobilité
électrique dès 2030
qui va jusqu'à l'objectif 2035 mais avec
bien sûr une infrastructure qui
accompagne infrastructure de bornes de
recharge électrique mais infrastructure
comme je l'ai dit aussi de station de
ravitaillement ou de points de recharge
hydrogène décarbonée et ça c'est
fondamental
la perspective de revoyure
qu'on peut traduire je pense que Marc
Mathurin est précédemment l'a bien
traduite c'est une analyse qui doit être
fait en disant faut amener au niveau
européen une notion de logique de
neutralité technologique et donc donner
la possibilité peut-être en 2035 si on
trouve une solution technique notre en
carbone de lui donner la possibilité
d'être utilisé mais comme je l'ai dit
déjà en 2035 il ne restera que peu
d'usages qui ne seront pas couverts pour
les véhicules légers et pour les
véhicules utilitaires légers par
les propositions que l'on a
donc on considère que une solution
alternative de combustion qui en plus ne
répond pas à la problématique que j'ai
évoquée tout à l'heure de qualité de
l'air parce que à partir du moment où
vous faites de la combustion que ça soit
un biocarburant que ça soit un biogaz
que ça soit un
ifyol de toute façon vous avez des notes
vous allez avoir un traitement
relativement lourd de ce qu'on appelle
de dépollution avec des réchauffages de
catalytiques avec des systèmes SCR un
peu partout avec des filtres à
particules et donc vous allez vous allez
avoir des solutions qui de toute façon
vont être mieux disons que les solutions
actuelles mais de toute façon polluantes
et donc un risque pour la santé publique
un certain nombre de sujets donc en fait
pour nous le au niveau des ventes une
solution alternative poste 2035 si elle
existe est intéressante pour qu'on
réponde pour y répondre à des usages
intensifs
donc on a on a déjà une première réponse
parce qu'on considère chez stellantis
que pour des usages très intensifs une
solution mixte électrique et fuel permet
de faire ces usages là donc c'est pour
ça qu'on propose depuis 2000-2023 on
propose des des fourgons des vannes en
fait Vivaro opel vivaro Peugeot Partner
Citroën Jumpy qui sont déjà des
solutions hybrides donc avec une
batterie significative vous avez des
batteries supérieures à 10 kWh embarqués
vous avez une pile à combustible de 40
40 kW ce qui vous permet en fait d'avoir
à la fois pour l'énergie la possibilité
d'utiliser votre système à hydrogène et
pour la puissance quand vous avez besoin
d'un appel de puissance utilisez une
batterie qui compense et qui permet en
fait l'ensemble et donc ça permet déjà
aussi avec des autonomies qui sont
significatives parce que en fonction
vous un van ça consomme en gros 1,2 kg
d'hydrogène en fait par donc vous avez
la possibilité d'avoir des autonomies si
vous embarquez 5 6 kg de d'hydrogène
d'avoir des autonomies de 500 600 km qui
sont proches de ce que l'habitude client
aujourd'hui et qui en plus en plus ces
solutions là ont des systèmes de
remplissage rapide un système de
remplissage en trois quatre minutes ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui de la
solution électrique et c'est vrai que la
solution électrique je sais pas si
beaucoup d'entre vous roulent en
électrique mais vous savez que quand on
est sur des voyages relativement longs
on a du mal en fait à garantir la même
prestation que la prestation qu'on a
avec un véhicule thermique d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
solution donc on a des solutions mais on
est ouvert à toute autre solution
la seule chose pour la clause de
revoyure va falloir vous définissiez ou
nous définition collectivement
c'est-à-dire l'ensemble de l'institution
publique et des industriels qu'est-ce
que signifie neutre en carbone
parce que aucune solution n'est neutre
en carbone comme vous le savez même les
véhicules à batterie ne sont pas neutres
en carbone si vous prenez une attitude
et c'est ça que nous défendons nous dans
nos analyses industrielles c'est qu'on
fait une attitude du ce qu'on appelle du
berceau à la tombe c'est-à-dire une
analyse de cycle de vie complète comme
vous l'avez dit je suis directeur du
programme analyse cycle de vie pour la
France donc c'est un sujet que bien sûr
qui me tient à cœur mais si on prend de
l'extraction des matières premières la
transformation la production des
véhicules et les usages voire le
recyclage aucun aucune solution
aujourd'hui respecte la totalité de la
tendue zéro émission 0 carbone ça
n'existe pas et en plus
donc la solution 0 carbone il faudra la
définir aujourd'hui si on raisonne au
niveau européen dans le texte pour les
véhicules particuliers la notion de 0
carbone c'est 0
= 0
et 0 = 0 à l'échappement et donc seule
solution qui respecte le texte européen
aujourd'hui donc avant la clause de
revoyure ce sont les solutions à
batterie ou à hydrogène
pour les camions c'est complètement
différent on a revu le texte vous saviez
que c'était au départ on considérait que
un camion qui consommait un gramme de
CO2 par kilowattheure pouvait être
considéré éventuellement notre en
carbone ou très faiblement carboné et
donc là on l'a rapporté en fait à des
solutions à la au gramme de CO2 à la
tonne embarquée en fait par km donc et
on a une limite à 5 g et ceci permet si
on veut respecter cette norme là des
usages intensifs pour les véhicules
lourds et donc des avec des carburants
qui sont utilisés donc les carburants
qui peuvent être utilisés le premier
c'est l'hydrogène l'hydrogène est un
carburant que nous pouvons utiliser pour
pour assurer notre mobilité et quand
vous parlez de carburant synthétique il
faut savoir que le carburant synthétique
dans la chaîne de valeur en fait il faut
comme j'ai dit il faut il faut qu'à la
fin ce carburant synthétique soit un
carburant décarbonée
pour être en des carburant des carbonés
il faut qu'il soit produit à partir
d'électricité des carbonée donc de
l'électricité qui décarbonée vous faites
de l'électrolyse de l'électrolyse ou
tirer de l'hydrogène donc vous passez
par la phase d'hydrogène puis vous
faites un gaz de type métal en associant
du carbone du CO2 mais pour faire pour
faire cette association si on l'a vous
devez capturer le carbone c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on capture comme ça
dans la nature c'est quelque chose qui
nécessite des installations
industrielles très fortes beaucoup
beaucoup de bétons et autres si vous
calculez justement le CO2 nécessaire
pour la réalisation des implantations
industrielles vous arrivez aussi à une
consommation de de CO2 et une fois que
vous avez associé cette capture de CO2
et cette hydrogène vous devez ensuite le
renforcer pour faire un
carburant lourd un fioul lourd qui
puisse essayer de transporter donc
l'intérêt du fioul lourd en fait c'est
quand même c'est son la facilité de
stockage et de transport
par contre comme il faut beaucoup
d'énergie globalement vous savez que
pour entre un véhicule électrique à
batterie et un véhicule hydrogène et
électrique à hydrogène vous avez déjà un
coef entre 2 et 3 de consommation
d'énergie pour un if you vous avez un
coefficient 5
donc une relativement importante et vous
comprenez très facilement que le coût le
coût à partir de moment où vous avez des
étapes supplémentaires pour aller vers
le if you les étapes supplémentaires à
l'hydrogène et ben le coût c'est
forcément plus cher
que l'hydrogène lui-même donc la
position de ces lentilles
à la situation actuelle de la
proposition faite par la Commission
européenne et par les gouvernements
américains et de développer
intensivement les véhicules électriques
pour des usages qu'il le permettent et
pour les usages qui ne le permettent pas
proposer des solutions hydrogènes
donc ça c'est la position c'est dentiste
vous avez évoquer les biocarburants et
les autres systèmes
en Europe
il y a quelque chose qui doit être pris
en compte aussi c'est la capacité entre
l'offre
et la demande donc en fait le
problématique c'est que s'il n'y a pas
d'offre
il y aura pas de d'usage de ces
solutions et un exemple que je prends
souvent pour les véhicules légers je
précise bien on a pris la décision parce
que il était très difficile de passer
les nouvelles normes de dépollution il y
a aucun constructeur automobile qui
propose un véhicule léger à partir de
2025 en véhicule léger au gaz par
exemple il y aura pas d'offre donc le
client ne pourra pas acheter n'aura pas
d'offre on n'a pas dans nos plans on
peut vous dire qu'on n'a pas dans nos
plans un certain nombre de technologies
les technologies qu'on privilégi c'est
celle qu'on a dit électrique hydrogène
et des solutions qui sont plus
accessibles pour aller jusqu'en 2035 et
on est très favorable à des solutions
hybridées qui sont des solutions qui
sont quand même très intéressantes n'ont
pas eu le soutien de l'institution
publique telle qu'on le souhaitait mais
qui sont des solutions importantes et
économiquement accessible entre
guillemets donc c'est la solution qu'on
défend et qu'on comprend en position de
le sémantisme
je regardais les questions comme ça ça
permet j'ai pratiquement répondu à
beaucoup je pense mais n'hésitez pas
[Musique]
quelles sont les attentes par rapport au
système il y a l'écosystème c'est ce que
j'ai dit principales attentes c'est de
l'énergie des carbonées et de
l'infrastructure donc il est très
important de mettre de l'infrastructure
alors pour information donc je prends
des une casquette un peu plus nationale
ou européenne au niveau des
infrastructures au niveau national vous
savez pour les véhicules électriques on
a proposé 100 000 stations de recharge
électrique en fait public à l'horizon
Emmanuel Macron avait dit fin 2021 mais
on a passé des mars 2023 le cap donc on
est on est aujourd'hui a déjà 100.000
véhicules stations de recharge
électrique ce qui est satisfaisant pour
le parc actuel
mais il faut avoir en tête que nos
prospectives et les offres qu'on va
proposer et les actions commerciales
qu'on va faire vis-à-vis de nos clients
et quand je dis nous c'est l'ensemble
des constructeurs automobiles
en Europe fait que en France on aura
besoin entre 400 et 600000 points de
recharge public de telle façon à
rassurer et permettre un usage
tel que le client l'attend de sa
mobilité ça veut dire que d'ici 2030 il
faut encore multiplier par 5
l'infrastructures
après on a pu voir en fait
globalement il y a de plus en plus la
recharge en fait se fait à domicile il
faudra absolument ou au travail il y a
tout un problème d'infras de démarche à
mettre en place de telle façon à
faciliter
même si mon opinion personnel n'a pas
valeur de statistiques
à titre personnel en fait je me recharge
beaucoup plus à domicile et que c'est
beaucoup plus simple et que je rechage
vraiment exceptionnellement en charge
publique c'est vraiment quand je fais de
l'itinérance mais sinon si vous faites
du du trajet pendulaire
vous revenez chez vous vous faites le
soir comme vous faites avec votre
téléphone vous branchez votre voiture
vous partez le matin vous êtes chargés
en fait et c'est très très agréable
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que la
mobilité électrique est encore une
mobilité très confortable c'est
l'expérience électrique est une très
bonne expérience les gens qui roulent en
électrique en fait apprécient
l'électrique s'il y avait pas de
contraintes associées il y aurait
beaucoup de beaucoup de sujets
en ce qui concerne les actions vis-à-vis
des acteurs on se considère comme un des
principales acteurs en fait au niveau de
la développement d'électricité et de la
mobilité électrique on travaille dessus
depuis des années on a plusieurs de nos
véhicules qui sont en tête des ventes
que ça soit chez lentis le niveau de la
208 électrique qui commence à se voir ou
de nos collègues italiens la Fiat 500
électrique est un modèle qui qui
commence à prendre des volumes
relativement significatifs on est
aujourd'hui tu me corriges jean-pascache
qu'on a 22% on a on a aujourd'hui 22% de
nos véhicules vendus qui sont vendus
électriques
actuellement alors que vous savez qu'en
France on est le si on regarde les
chiffres du mois de du mois d'avril je
pense que Nicolas et Marc ont dû
signaler mais on est autour de 21 22% de
véhicules électriques plus véhicule
hybride rechargeable c'est à dire en
moyenne pour l'ensemble du marché on est
sur 13% de voitures électriques et 8 ou
9% de véhicules électriques
surchargeables donc le groupe c'est
l'antis comme le groupe Volkswagen
certains grands groupes qui ont pris le
virage déjà sont déjà beaucoup plus
significativement
significativement en avance après la
question
c'est une question donc vous disiez
Carlos Tavares a dit qu'il faut pas faut
sortir du dogme en fait du véhicule
électrique la bonne question c'est qu'il
faut pas te donner la solution parce
qu'il y a pas une solution le problème
c'est qu'il faut traiter le sujet à
travers nos usages et pour des usages
comme je l'ai dit en fonction de comment
vous quelqu'un qui fait je vais
rencontrer
une société de livraison qui disait bah
moi quand je fais 200 km par jour et que
je fais je reviens à moi une solution
électrique me va tout à fait bien par
contre si je fais de l'Intérieur urbain
et que je fais 300 400 km moi j'ai
toujours peur de pas aller au bout et
donc il dit moi il me faut autre chose
donc il faut proposer autre chose alors
ça peut être de l'hydrogène ça peut être
un carburant biocarburant un certain
nombre de choses donc
la volonté de Carlos Tavares c'est de
dire un il faut pas donner la solution
mais il faut traiter par les usages et
même si nous avons déjà pris la décision
de fortement décarboner l'ensemble de
l'entreprise et des usages de nos
produits
et avons pris une orientation électrique
parce que c'est ce qui nous a été
demandé il faut il faut le faire mais il
y a la possibilité de regarder et depuis
plusieurs années l'automobile est quand
même une société bon moi ça fait 38 ans
que que je travaille dans l'automobile
j'ai fait que ça j'ai été directeur
technique de trois constructeurs j'ai eu
la chance de passer en France en
Allemagne et en Italie
j'étais en charge des avant-projets et
des innovations chez PSA comme vous le
dites et donc
l'innovation a toujours permis de
trouver des solutions à quoi je suis
plutôt optimiste faut pas être
on a des ingénieurs de très bonne
qualité on est capable de trouver des
solutions et de le faire donc il y a en
fonction des usages il y a des
opportunités et un certain nombre de
choses donc la première chose que
souhaitait dire qu'à Musta Vares c'est
un traité d'abord une notion d'usage
donnez-nous des objectifs techniques et
nous on proposera les solutions et ayons
une approche une approche beaucoup plus
réaliste et c'est à dire avec une
approche qui va
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure en
analyse cycle de vie du berceau à la
tombe si possible c'est à dire qu'une
relation un peu plus globale et qui
prend en compte l'écosystème c'est à
dire l'énergie qui prend en compte en
fait l'infrastructure un certain nombre
de choses donc son propos c'est ça c'est
d'avoir une cohérence d'ensemble et de
et de réussir en fait à la proposer
la deuxième chose parce que il s'est
exprimé aussi sur les fuel dernièrement
il faut avoir en tête que notre parc
aujourd'hui vendu ne représente en fait
que 5% du parc roulant
c'est à dire que 5 %. c'est à dire que
vous pouvez mettre 100 % de véhicules
électriques cette année vous aurez quand
même 95% de véhicules qui vont rouler
avec les moteurs qu'ils avaient les
années précédentes donc en fait si on
veut réellement avoir une action de
décarbonation il est fondamental qu'on
s'occupe du parc
et le parc c'est un parc qui a
malheureusement vieillissant d'ailleurs
parce que je crois qu'on est je sais pas
de on doit être pas loin de 10 ou 11 ans
aujourd'hui le parc est assez
vieillissant et la majorité des voitures
qui roulent ne sont pas et vous le savez
bien parce que c'est le problème qu'on a
dans les discours avec les ZFE et les
usagers il y a des voitures qui sont en
dessous du critère 3 il y a encore des
voitures critères 2 et un certain nombre
de choses et donc je pense qu'ils
importants de s'occuper du parc et donc
on parle de biocarburant ou de
choses de ce type ou c'est des solutions
qui sont beaucoup plus adaptées au parc
roulant il a il est fondamental que ces
solutions permettent en fait ce qu'on
appelle une solution de droping c'est à
dire qu'on puisse capable sur les
véhicules actuels de proposer des
carburants
moins polluant ou maintenant en carbone
qui permettent de rouler et qui ont un
impact en fait sur le réchauffement
climatique immédiat et beaucoup plus
rapide que de que de contraintes en fait
les les véhicules vendus donc en fait la
solution biocarburant
if you est une solution qui est adaptée
pour le parc et c'est fondamental et qui
peut être une opportunité si il est
disponible en quantité suffisante peut
être une opportunité pour des usages
très intensifs
les usages intensifs vous savez qu'on a
retardé le l'application 2035 d'un an
pour ce qu'on a appelé l'amendement
Ferrari au niveau de Bruxelles c'est à
dire que permettent aux véhicules de
vendus à moins de 10 000 exemplaires de
ne pas passer ce bain thermique en 2035
et en fait la proposition qui a été
discutée avec les avec les Allemands
dernièrement donc de réfléchir à laisser
l'opportunité fioul c'est vrai qu'elle a
adapté pour des usages intensifs un des
usages intensifs et c'est pas
caricatural c'est l'usage sportif et
c'est vrai que pour une Porsche 911
c'est peut-être la solution de maintenir
en fait les usages de ce type de
véhicule autant on a appelé la demande
Ferrari l'amendement précédent cet
amendement là c'est presque un
amendement Porsche mais globalement
voilà le le la situation donc
globalement on est dans cette logique de
décarbonation
on a de l'opportunité on dira qu'on des
opportunités et donc en fait en fonction
des hypothèses si réellement il y a des
solutions qui sont zéro émission qui
sont
potentiellement qui permettent d'accéder
aux souhaitent le client c'est accéder
en ville un certain nombre de choses si
vous interdisez des émissions en ville
c'est à dire que vous interdisez toutes
les véhicules thermiques de la même
façon si vous interdisez des ce qu'on
appelle des des pie face ou un certain
nombre de choses voilà interdire un
certain nombre aussi de de
caractéristiques et de composants donc
il est important d'avoir ça à l'esprit
et donc pour la mobilité routière
légère le
carburant synthétique au biocarburant
sur des véhicules neufs c'est un
épiphénomène qui sera regardé que par
opportunité après ce qu'il faut avoir à
l'esprit comme j'ai dit comme il est
important de traiter le parc nous on est
très favorable et nos moteurs le
permettent aujourd'hui d'augmenter les
taux de bio dans les carburants actuels
c'est-à-dire que les moteurs neufs
produits depuis 4-5 ans sont compatibles
de ce qu'on appelle du B1 du E30 donc là
on est à b75/10 je crois de mémoire mais
elles sont compatibles à son compatibles
en fait de solution un peu plus un peu
plus importantes et ce qui a fait ce qui
a demandé Carlos Tavares c'est que si il
était proposé dans des solutions de
carburant synthétiques sur le marché
qu'on soit certains que ça puisse
profiter au parc et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il a demandé à ce qu'on fasse des
tests sur 28 moteurs et donc les 28
moteurs qu'on voit aujourd'hui si vous
mettez un diesel ou une essence
d'aujourd'hui si vous mettez un essence
de deux mains et bien ils auront la même
caractéristique de pollution et les
mêmes prestations de fonctionnement
qu'attendent des clients donc il y aura
pas de perte de prestation c'est ça qui
est fondamental et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on dit bah s'il y en a nous nos
moteurs du parc il les accepte
s'il y a des usages qu'on peut pas
assurer par l'électrique et qu'on peut
pas assurer par l'hydrogène on regardera
autre chose mais c'est pas une stratégie
de développement
et d'ailleurs vous l'avez lu aussi dans
le texte les développements de moteur
thermique sont plus sont plus pris en
compte dans notre entreprise et dans les
entreprises
comme Renault qui je peux parler pour
les deux parce que je les représentent
en tant que président du CCFA mais
globalement les développements de
nouveaux moteurs pour l'instant sont
quand même un peu en stand-by
donc c'est un peu le la stratégie après
il reste
je sais pas si évoqué l'ensemble il
reste la le problème de l'accessibilité
à la mobilité
il est vrai que aujourd'hui
si on parle de véhicules électriques un
véhicule électrique si il embarque en
nous c'est je sais pas si on a beaucoup
de si la Fiat 500 à la 20 kilowattheure
normalement dans nos prochains modèles
en fait on va on va proposer en fait des
des quantités de batterie embarquées
différentes en fonction et donc le
client pourra payer en fait s'il veut
plus ou moins d'autonomie donc il aura
une plus grosse batterie mais plus de
poids et ainsi de suite donc sur les
segments c'est à dire au-delà de la 308
on sera plutôt sur des propositions du
type 40 60 kWh embarqués sur des
saignements haut de gamme il est
possible qu'on aille sur des valeurs
très importantes un Tesla a montré à
montrer la route entre guillemets par
contre sur des petites voitures on peut
être amené à mettre que 20 kilowatts
embarqués en sachant que normalement
quand vous êtes sur un roulage urbain ou
périurbain vous vous devez consommer
moins de 20 kilowatts ou 100 km en
kilowatts ou 100 km si vous avez 20
kilowatts embarqués bon ça ça vous
permet quand même de de faire un certain
nombre d'usages du quotidien et si vous
avez la facilité de pouvoir vous
recharger parce que l'infrastructure est
présente
ça peut permettre de faire le truc donc
faire du déconting de batterie et de
décontenking de véhicule c'est vertueux
c'est vertueux mais ça demande à ce que
l'infrastructure soit en place
et c'est la solution pour pour baisser
les coûts parce que donc nous on a on a
un engagement interne de 40% dans le
droit de le dire donc on a un engagement
interne en fait à partir du moment où un
développement massique de nos voitures
électriques et pris en compte quand je
dis massique quand on dit c'est
plusieurs millions de véhicules
électriques on va produire en Europe
pour l'Europe et donc c'est le volume
l'automobile est une industrie de volume
donc cette industrie de volume permet de
de baisser les coûts et donc on a on a
en objective de baisser les coûts 40%.
donc aujourd'hui ce qui est étonnant
dans le dans le
la perception que les gens ont de la
voiture électrique vous avez deux types
de perception vous avez la perception
qui est un peu intellectuelle du coup à
l'usage complet le TCO et donc vous avez
un coup d'achat qui est plutôt élevé
et puis vous allez parcours un coup
d'usage qui normalement plus faible même
si on dit les signaux qu'on a eu sur le
prix de l'électricité était pas très
favorable mais normalement
on devrait pas être à 120 euros du
mégawatt aujourd'hui on devrait être
plus bas et donc le coup le coup à
l'usage et quand même beaucoup plus
faible en véhicule électrique qu'il est
en véhicule en véhicule
thermique surtout surtout si on se
recharge comme je disais au travail ou
au domicile après vous avez vu sur
autoroute il y en a qui ont profité de
des coudes des recharges rapides pour
les avec des coûts qui ont été de
mémoire
avant sa tournée autour de 79 centimes
le kilowattheure mais il y en a qui sont
passés jusqu'à 1 Euro 5 il y a pas si
longtemps ça donc sur autoroute et quand
vous faites le bilan comme vous
quelqu'un qui roule à 130 km/h lui
consomme pas 20 kilowattheure ou 100 km
comme j'ai dit mais il va consommer s'il
est avec une une berline plutôt
ou plutôt 35 s'il est avec un suive à
une surface frontale supérieure donc
vous avez plus de résistance au
roulement ou avec un van vous allez
pouvoir utiliser sur des roulages
autoroutes tel qu'on a l'habitude
aujourd'hui des vitesses qui vont vous
obliger de consommer 30 40 kilowatts ou
100 km si vous embarquez que 60 70 kWh
de batterie ça veut dire que vous
arrêtez que que au bout de deux heures
en fait moins de deux heures vous faites
deux heures vous arrêtez vous rechargez
une demi-heure donc il y a toute une
logique en fait qui est nécessaire et le
coût de recharge sur autoroute
aujourd'hui en recharge rapide et
voisins en fait du coup qu'on retrouve
quand on recharge avec un carburant
classique donc il y a tout un travail
d'écosystème et c'est ça qui est
fondamental à avoir en tête faut pas
parler des véhicules c'est l'ancien
monde faut parler de la mobilité donc
nous en tant que deux groupes on parle
on se positionne comme provider de
mobilité mais il faut voir l'écosystème
au sens large et regarder la vision
globale en fait que l'on a sur sur le
système
donc on a on a l'ambition d'ici 2030 de
baisser quand même significativement
le coût complet du véhicule électrique
et le coût facial néanmoins le coût
facial sera probablement toujours
supérieure ou faciale aujourd'hui d'un
véhicule une batterie un moment donné
vous êtes contraint par la quantité
matière la quantité d'énergie nécessaire
à la fabriquer et aller au delà d'ici
2030 qui quand même dans 7 ans
arrivé à être plus bas que 100 euros au
kilowattheure ça sera pas possible et
comme je dis que la moyenne nous
actuellement la moyenne que l'on voit
actuellement elle est plutôt autour de
50 euros kilowatts embarqués par le
véhicule donc ça veut dire que si vous
êtes entre 30 et 50
kWh par véhicule embarqué vous avez
entre 3000 et 5000 euros de de coût en
fait de additionnel à la voiture et vous
ne baisserez pas le coût de la voiture
sur les technologies classiques de cette
même valeur donc facilement le véhicule
électrique sera toujours un peu plus
cher que le véhicule thermique
équivalent en usage aujourd'hui par
contre dans son usage ça coûtera
nettement moins cher si on est capable
de contrôler le prix d'électricité
donc c'est ça qui est c'est ça qui est
fondamental et il faut savoir que que ça
soit au niveau de
des courbes de de
l'usage en fait dans la des Carbos de la
carbonation ou la contribution carbone
d'un véhicule aujourd'hui c'est quand
même 70 à 80 %
de la contribution carbone donc si on
passe d'un véhicule thermique un
véhicule électrique la production ça
vous fait je sais pas c'est aujourd'hui
c'est 6 tonnes de CO2 par véhicule en
moyenne vous passez à 11 tonnes
peut-être en véhicule électrique mais là
l'usage avec un véhicule thermique c'est
30 tonnes de CO2 donc de toute façon les
courses se croisent ça dit autrement la
voiture électrique est toujours plus
vertueuse
toujours plus vertueuse que la voiture
thermique et d'autant plus que
l'électricité sera décarbonée parce que
si vous avez l'électricité complètement
décarbonée vous croisez très très vite
je crois qu'en France on a établi avec
l'énergie nucléaire c'est c'est très peu
de kilomètres c'est trop tôt dans le
mille et 50 000 km ou les courses se
croisent elles peuvent se croiser
beaucoup plus donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les gens vous disent
l'Allemagne la Pologne ont des sons des
pays qui ont des des grammes de CO2 au
kilowatt-heure produit qui sont énormes
et qui sont 7 fois à peu près le la
valeur qu'on a en France mais il faut
pas penser qu'en 2030 ou en 2040 on va
rester comme ça ils vont passer à des
énergies renouvelables ils vont
diminuer leur l'impact de du charbon et
ainsi de suite donc si on se projette à
10 ou à 15 ans la voiture électrique est
toute façon plus vertueuse que la
voiture thermique
dans les autres questions vous nous
aviez posé
comment comment pensez-vous que la
Commission
considère en fait les émissions de CO2
que Dupuis à la queue du réservoir à la
roue en fait
oui c'est pas c'est pas propre en tant
que guillemets son jeu de mots donc nous
on est favorable en fait à une prise en
compte d'une analyse cycle de vie
comprenne en compte toute la chaîne de
production de valeur et d'usage
néanmoins c'est très difficile à
contrôler et à mesurer donc aujourd'hui
de la même façon que vous
êtes obligé entre guillemets de prendre
des notions de CO2 pour justifier un peu
le les
[Musique]
véhicules à faible emprunt
environnemental c'est parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus difficile donc de mettre
des normes par exemple d'entrer dans les
villes mesurée par rapport à la quantité
de NOx ça serait quelque chose de plus
difficile donc en fait c'est on est on
est favorable scientifiquement à
l'analyse économie la prise de analycle
de vie on comprend quand même que ça
demande beaucoup de travail pour être
homogénéisé
nous avons produit donc au niveau de la
filière automobile donc Renault PSA
inclus une méthodologie je l'ai publié
il y a pas longtemps c'était la semaine
dernière donc une méthodologie qui
qu'on souhaite appliquer partout et qui
on veut
la méthodologie de référence en fait
pour parler d'analyse cycle de vie il
est fondamental et vous comprendrez très
vite si je parlais tout à l'heure de
l'impact de l'usage si un ONG prend
100000 km comme référence d'usage pour
faire le bilan et nous on constate que
nos clients roulent 150 200 170 km avec
les mêmes les mêmes véhicules parce
qu'on a les données par nos ordinateurs
de bord on sait comment sont les usages
et l'utilisation le résultat est
complètement différent
et donc
le problème de l'analyse cycle de vie
c'est que vous êtes capable d'avoir des
résultats qui sont
contradictoires entre la façon de les
gens dont les pronoms donc il est
fondamental qui est toujours une analyse
critique sur les données une analyse
critique sur la méthode et nous on
souhaite donc au niveau de la filière
automobile dire voilà la méthodologie
et elle est scientifiques elle est la
science et n'est pas contestable en fait
on a la même quel que soit sa couleur
quel que soit son pays la mathématique
et la physique et la même pour tout le
monde donc voilà la méthodologie
physique et mettez des mathéique on a
les données d'usage on a les données de
d'impact environnemental de l'ensemble
des pièces en fonction d'où elles sont
fabriquées comment elles sont fabriquées
ainsi de suite donc voilà les données la
base de données voilà la méthodologie si
vous voulez faire une mesure voilà
comment vous la faites et donc nous on
acceptera et en fait on validera en fait
des des communications autour de cet
impact environnemental que si une
méthodologie une base de données
certifiée et c'est ce que souhaite
l'Europe
l'Europe va travailler donc moi j'étais
jusqu'à juillet 2021 directeur
environnement la CEA donc l'association
de des constructeurs automobiles
européens
et donc si on travaillait sur ce sujet
là avec avec les directions générales de
l'Europe de telle façon avec le JRC le
gent pour avoir en fait une méthodologie
pareil qui soit unique et commune donc
c'est assez ça c'est fondamental
est-ce que j'ai des sujets que j'ai pas
abordé
bon la concurrence chinoise qui a été
évoquée ou c'est un vrai débat
le problème que l'on a sur aujourd'hui
c'est que on maîtrisait on maîtrisait la
technologie des moteurs thermiques et en
France particulièrement la méthode de la
fabrication et le développement des
moteurs diesel
et là on est en pleine transition donc
cette transition comme je l'ai dit si on
veut prendre le virage elle nous impose
d'aller vers une électrification massive
et sur l'électrification massive en fait
on s'aperçoit que c'est vrai les Chinois
ont pris le virage avant nous
ils ont pris le virage avant nous avec
deux actions
le premier ils ont l'avantage d'avoir un
certain nombre de matériaux critiques et
stratégiques sur leur propre sol
et d'avoir exploité des mines pour les
extraire
ils ont aussi eu l'avantage de
d'investir énormément et de ne plus
investir de pas se battre en fait sur le
moteur thermique en fait ils sont passés
sur le coup d'après en ayant
stratégiquement vu arriver le moteur
électrique le véhicule électrique
d'investir dans les dans les mines si
vous regardez les mines de cobalt au en
République du Congo un font 80,75 à 80 %
de la production mondiale sur un petit
pays mais 80% des investissements de ce
pays là sont chinois et en plus les
usines de raffinage qui ramènent à la
qualité nécessaire pour fabriquer les
batteries sont en Chine on a peu de
rising de raffinage donc un autre une
autre chose qui est importante et
Philippe Varin l'a bien signalé on a
travaillé avec Philippe sur sur le
rapport qui a été qui a été présenté et
maintenant bon Benjamin galzeau reprend
donc
délégué interministériel sur les
matériaux stratégiques on prend le sujet
mais il est fondamental que l'Europe se
dot de plusieurs sujets donc les sujets
c'est la capacité de raffiner pourquoi
capacité de raffiner parce que si on
veut recycler nos batteries on va mettre
un nombre important de véhicules
électriques si on prend la France et
qu'on prend l'objectif de que nous a
signé Emmanuel Macron normalement on a 2
millions de véhicules électrifiés
produits en France en 2030
c'est l'engagement qui a été pris on en
aura probablement un million 7 un
million 8 mais bon
la problématique de ces engagements là
c'est pas c'est pas de tenir la date
c'est de donner le cap et c'est comme
les bandes de chats que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que 100000 en 2021
c'était ambitieux mais on l'a passé
100000 en 2023 et si on s'était pas fixé
ce câble de 100 000 en 2021 je pense pas
qu'on sera à 100 millions 2023 donc le
problème c'est pas de savoir si on va le
passer en 2030 en 2032 en 2033 c'est
c'est vraiment la bonne direction et
donc on va on va avoir quand même des
quantités et donc vous savez qu'on a des
quantités de batterie et de matériaux
critiques qui sont nécessaires qui sont
phénoménales donc si vous parlez 2
millions de voitures à 50 kilos à
kilowattheure embarqués vous faites le
calcul ça fait 100 GW 100 GW ça veut
dire qu'il faut au minimum 3 giga
factori en France on a l'avantage
qu'avec les ipcv important de Project
forum intéresse on a aidé nos
entreprises industrielles et qu'on a
dans le haut de France on est on en
annonce 4 maintenant
c'est déclaré aussi
on a 4 Go Factory potentiellement en
France donc on voit que on se met en or
de bataille pour pouvoir produire on se
met en ordre de bataille
pour pouvoir il va falloir se mettre en
ordre de bataille pour pouvoir recycler
ces batteries en fin de vie et pour
pouvoir retraiter les matériaux qu'on
récupérera donc très fondamental d'avoir
du recyclage et du raffinage en Europe
dans les dans les années qui viennent
tout ce qu'on peut
on va peut-être passer la parole
merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
vice-président d'abord ravi de vous
avoir ici devant la devant la mission
c'est pas tous les constructeurs qui qui
viennent et on est sensible à l'intérêt
que vous portez à nos travaux c'est très
éclairant le propos que vous nous avez
tenu vous avez abordé énormément de
questions donc du coup je n'aurais pas
tant que ça
je voulais juste
bien sérieux peut-être en forme de
points que vous avez abordé pour être
certain que nous ayons bien
saisi les réponses telles que vous les
avez apportées
d'abord vous avez fait un plaidoyer
quand même pour le véhicule électrique
très clair en me disant de notre
orientation est bien celle là on l'a
entendu comme tel mais électricité et
hydrogène
alors après la question c'est comment se
répartissent des choses entendues comme
beaucoup là-dessus vous êtes pas très
différent que c'est les usages qui vont
permettre de voir
jusqu'où on va sur l'hydrogène jusque là
on n'avez pas le sentiment quand même
que c'était lentis était si on pointe
que sa potentiellement sur l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui personne je vais terminer
regardez deuxième point quand vous
abordez l'hybride alors vous ne dites
l'hybride moi j'ai noté batterie pile à
combustible donc je comprends batterie
électrique et hydrogène tout à fait
alors ça c'est un type d'hybride que
jusque là on voit pas trop quand même
donc vous vous y croyez et pour quel
type d'usage ça ça nous intéresse j'ai
plusieurs questions vous allez vous
répondre tranquillement ensuite
sur les biocarburants et les fioules bon
ce que je comprends c'est que vous nous
dites ça peut être une solution pour
décarboner le parc existant
bon donc est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une merci de le dire d'abord parce
que c'est une orientation qui est
pragmatique et merci de nous rappeler
qu'à 5% de production tous les ans qui
renouvellent le barque mais qui a 95 %
qui reste donc il faut s'en préoccuper
notre notre travail nous c'est d'essayer
de regarder comment on peut décarboner
avec elle carburant ou quel vecteur bon
donc
là dessus est-ce que cette idée de
biocarburant et de fioul pour pour le
parc existant vous paraît partager par
les pouvoirs publics à ce stade est-ce
que la filière le plaid et jusqu'où on
peut aller bon et enfin dernier point
sur l'analyseur
je posais tout à l'heure la question à
la plateforme je vous propose la même
est-ce que le combat peut être gagné à
certains égards on peut dire qu'il y a
des clauses de revoyure qui a la
question de l'acte délégué gagné par les
Allemands etc sur sur les carburants et
fioul bon et que donc l'analyse en cycle
de vie va revenir
nous on a plutôt tendance à déplorer
jusque là elle est pas été dominante
comme sujet voilà bon mais donc vous
vous êtes prêts à mener ce combat en
disant il faut réfléchir vraiment en
analyse ici de vie maintenant et du coup
quelle conclusion on va qu'est-ce que
vous en attendez comme conséquence
derrière d'accord
l'hydrogène en fait c'est vraiment un
choix un choix stratégique de style qui
a été pris il y a plusieurs années vous
savez qu'on a commencé à présenter nos
piles à combustible en 2006 sur la base
307 cabriolet 3008 donc c'est un sujet
qu'on connaît comme l'électrique à un
moment donné la problématique c'est de
trouver le bon moment avec le bon
business model c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné
l'hydrogène n'a d'intérêt que celui
d'hydrogène et vert donc il faut bien
avoir ça à l'esprit si l'hydrogène est
pas vert ça aucun impact favorable sur
la décarbonation donc il faut de
l'hydrogène vert là aujourd'hui on a des
acteurs qui s'engagent en fait dans
l'hydrogène verse soit à travers de
l'électrolyse associée à l'énergie
renouvelable soit à travers de
nucléaire soit à travers de la biomasse
et et des sujets donc on a des acteurs
qui le font et l'écosystème s'est mis en
route et c'est vrai que le plan national
hydrogène qui a été défini quand même
9,1 milliards pour avec l'avenant de
qu'on a fait a mis en place donc c'est
lentilles sinon à choisi très rapidement
parce que en fait on a fait l'analyse
nous sur la partie des usages et donc on
a toujours dit que tous les usages ne
sont pas couverts par le roulage
électrique à batterie et donc il y avait
besoin d'une solution pour des sujets
donc on a regardé une démarche en tant
qu'industrielle on regarde ce qu'on
appelle les profits de poules c'est où
on peut rentabiliser un investissement
sur un domaine et pour l'hydrogène les
profits de poules pour nous ils sont
pour les endroits où il y a des usages
intensifs que vous retrouvez sur les
véhicules utilitaires léger qui qui ont
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure un vécu
hier avec une surface frontale c'est
quand même des voitures qui sont
massivement importantes qui sont souvent
lourdes et chargés et donc vous devez
besoin et vous n'avez pas des
consommations comme une véhicule urbain
donc vous avez besoin de solutions et
donc ils ont en usage intensif et en
plus c'est dans les moyens que les les
véhicules de commerciaux que vous vous
retrouvez des usages où les gens ils
disent bah moi j'ai besoin d'utiliser
mon véhicule en 2,8
j'ai une première équipe qui tourne avec
la deuxième équipe elle arrive elle
repart vous pouvez pas le faire avec un
véhicule électrique aujourd'hui parce
que la recharge rapide que qui serait
nécessaire n'existe pas aujourd'hui donc
c'est une solution qui rapporte donc
nous en termes en termes d'usage le
véhicule hydrogène est adapté aux
véhicules utilitaires légers
au flotte qui font du pire tout pire
donc les taxis par exemple et donc vous
savez que vous avez hype ice & Co qui
qui travaille sur le sujet au bus parce
que c'est du zéro émission un bus
général ça va en ville entre guillemets
donc c'est du zéro émission et bien sûr
au camion à usage très intensif en
particulier à ceux qui font des longues
distances vous avez des camions qui font
des Berlins Barcelone et qui font des 1
million cinq de kilomètres par
durant toute leur vie en faisant des
distances entre 800 et 1000 1500 km
parfois par jour et ça vous pouvez vous
pouvez le faire que avec une solution
alternative de carburant alternatif qui
soit hydrogène ou ifiulent ou biogaz
c'est que ça parce que sans ça si vous
le faites
c'est pas pour rien qu'aujourd'hui ils
sont tous diesel entre guillemets si
vous en électriques vous allez embarquer
beaucoup plus de tonnages de batterie
que de ton âge de de commerciaux entre
guillemets donc c'est important donc
nous en ce qui nous concerne on se
positionne sur les véhicules utilitaires
légers et aujourd'hui on a présenté dès
le plan d'électrification des air forwan
2030 on a présenté cette stratégie et on
a on a mis on a développé donc depuis
trois quatre ans un véhicule utilitaire
et le véhicule utilitaire aujourd'hui il
est en vente
on est c'est une réalité c'est à dire
que quand dans un plan hydrogène on vous
parle le dire il faut d'abord des
carboner
l'industrie cimenterie à Syrie puis
peut-être des carboner dans la mobilité
ceux qui ont le plus besoin et faire un
avion à hydrogène ou un bateau ainsi de
suite l'avion hydrogène vous voyez pas
avant 2035 là en 2023 vous vous pouvez
acheter un véhicule silenti ça hydrogène
il est en vente donc c'est ça qui est
important et donc il ne consomment pas
les volumes importants mais il est déjà
en réalité alors nos stratégiquement on
démonte notre je n'ai pas dit mais notre
positionnement stratégique vous le voyez
par nos investissements
vous avez vu que pour les véhicules
électriques on a investi on est on est
actionnaire de ACC donc Automotive
celle-ci
qui a comme plan en Europe de produire
120 gigawh de batterie par an sur trois
sites un site qui a Douvrin en France
donc 40 un peu plus de 40 giga en
hauteur dans après les années 2030 ainsi
à Kaiser sautern et un site à terminer
donc on a trois sites en Europe pour
produire et qui sont à proximité nos
usines terminales c'est à dire qu'on a
en tête de produire à proximité quand on
est à Douvrin vous savez qu'à ordin
comme je l'ai dit aujourd'hui on va
faire des des utilitaires électriques
les utilitaires et hydrogène aujourd'hui
sont produits à russenshine
ils sont produits à russiansham avec une
démarche de production qui est plutôt
j'allais dire je sais pas j'aime pas le
terme prototype mais
pas complètement industriel parce qu'on
produit un véhicule électrique en France
qu'on transporte en Allemagne on démonte
le moteur électrique et la batterie et
on le remplace par un des réservoirs en
carbone donc hydrogène et une pile à
combustible
donc ça donne un véhicule qu'on peut
vendre ce CRS par contre il reste cher
mais on est dans une industrie nous qui
est une industrie comme je l'ai dit où
les volumes c'est une industrie de
volume dès qu'on met en des volumes
importants les coûts baissent épaisse
signification et donc si vous regardez
le cas de nos productions à hydrogène
Carlos Tavares s'est engagé à transférer
donc en 2024
les productions à ordin sur les mêmes
lignes en quelques véhicules électriques
et en plus il a dit qu'on ferait 5000
véhicules en 2024 10 000 en 2025 voire
30 000 après dans la deuxième la
deuxième partie de la décennie en
capacité à installer donc on a cette
proposition là et nos clients le
demandent si vous regardez un UPS la
poste ou des choses comme ça comme je
l'ai dit ceux qui font de l'intérêt
régional ils ont s'ils veulent affiché
une entreprise qui s'occupe et se
préoccupe de la décarbonation ils n'ont
pas d'autres solutions que que de
s'orienter vers ce son là donc on a des
clients qui sont identifiés on a des
partenariats on a fait un partenariat
avec engie et donc si vous regardez sur
l'hydrogène le le donc engie c'est pour
les stations je pense que si vous
regardez sur l'hydrogène vous avez une
annonce cette semaine on vient on vient
d'investir 150 millions dans saint bio
on a pris 33% de Saint bio vous croyez
vous croyez que Monsieur Tavares si vous
parlez de de si on parle globalement
batterie monde
460 gigawh
industrialisé aujourd'hui dans le monde
en fait avec 5 giga Factory vous savez
que globalement je vais pas rentrer dans
les détails des chiffres mais si on
prend un milliard par gigawattheure
toute façon vous l'aurez trouvé à
travers les ipci ou vous savez combien
la France a aidé subventionné les
usines de batterie mais si vous si vous
êtes 460 gigawh et 1 milliard pour 10 GW
on parle de 46 milliards est-ce que vous
pensez qu'une entreprise privée
industrielle qui investit c'est des
montants aussi importants dans des
technologies n'y crois pas c'est
impossible
ce qu'on comprend pas c'est que les gens
ne comprennent pas que que le train est
parti en fait le train est parti on
investit massivement et donc la
meilleure croyance que je peux vous
apporter pour démontrer excellentiste
croire à la solution hydrogène c'est
l'investissement qu'on vient de faire
dans un bio
et on l'a fait cette semaine j'ai pas
fait exprès que le communiqué de presse
est paru la veille de cette audition
c'est complètement
mais on vient de le faire la deuxième
chose alors pourquoi sont rentrés dans
la technique pourquoi
pourquoi je parle de ça en fait quand
les gens parlent d'hybride rechargeable
hybride ça veut pas dire avec un moteur
thermique il brise ça veut dire avec
deux types de propulsion ou de vecteurs
énergétiques donc nous on a appris le
choix parce qu'on a regardé
technologiquement et techniquement
quelle était la meilleure solution
meilleure bilan technico économique on a
des batteries qui sont relativement
chères et on a des batteries dont on
n'est pas certain d'avoir la totalité
des matériaux sinus stratégiques qui
seraient nécessaires d'ailleurs pour la
même prestation une voiture qui devrait
faire pour un véhicule utilitaire léger
400 km d'autonomie si je mettais un 35
kilowatts de 2 kWh 100 km et que je lui
demande de faire 500 km ça veut dire
Jean-Marc entre 150 120 150 kWh minimum
et donc un coût très élevé donc
l'équilibre c'est un équilibre entre le
coût et et l'énergie embarquée
l'avantage d'avoir une solution hybride
qui permet un roulage donc en électrique
donc une solution hybride comme j c'est
une batterie de puissance qui a deux
avantages elle apporte des appels de
puissance quand vous voulez accélérer
vite quand vous voulez un certain nombre
monter une montagne et qui permet aussi
de rouler vraiment zéro émission aussi
mais dans des des phases
urbaines et autres associés à de
l'énergie qui est apportée pour faire le
roulement minimum qui est nécessaire par
une pile à combustible ça vous
dimensionne la pile à combustible de
façon
assez limité parce qu'on parle de 40 kW
si je voulais qu'elle fasse tout je
serais obligé de mettre une 100 120
kilowatts entre guillemets et ça
coûterait plus cher donc le meilleur
équilibre entre une batterie et et
une pile à combustible en fait non pour
l'instant le meilleur équilibre c'est
pas à 100 % puis la combustible c'est
pas 100% batterie c'est un mixte des
deux et en fonction des évolutions des
prix parce que quand les piles à
combustibles vont prendre des volumes
importants donc on a annoncé tu mal lu
le communiqué presque 50 000 en 2027
pile et 100 000 en 2030 mais des volumes
suffisants qui vont baisser de la même
façon les prix de façon significative 40
à 50% à ce moment là il y aura des
adaptations et l'adaptation idéalement à
terme si l'hydrogène est décarbonée si
l'hydrogène est inférieure à 4 euros au
kilo et si on est capable de baisser les
coûts des réservoirs et des piles en
ayant des volumes
l'avantage sera quand même pour certains
usages à la pile à combustible et donc
de plus en plus vous aurez une pile à
combustible qui aura des puissances plus
élevées pour aller vers du fioul ce
qu'on appelle du fioul Power et des
batteries beaucoup plus faibles donc
après c'est une question stratégique et
de vision en fait de ce qu'on voit donc
nous dans notre perception
on croit absolument au sujet et comme je
l'ai dit c'est pas c'est pas c'est un
peu caricatural mais 80% de nos usages
aujourd'hui de mobilité sont assurés par
la véhicule le véhicule électrique donc
le
la vision de demain c'est 80% des
électriques 15 % électrique plus
hydrogène et puis si il y a des
usages qu'on n'arrive pas à assurer par
cela il y aura peut-être quelque chose
qui restera peut-être mais
il faut pas faut pas vous savez que les
électrochimiques batteries les piles à
combustibles j'étais
avec une société une startup qui est en
train de développer justement le
transfert électrochimique dans les dans
les membranes
elle multiplie par 10 les performances
pour pour les piles à combustibles pour
les batteries on a quand même beaucoup
d'espoir avec ce qu'on appelle la
batterie solid state donc à l'électronic
solide on a beaucoup d'espoir sur des
solutions alternatives pour des
véhicules qui sont qui sont pas
forcément
cher donc de mettre des solutions où LFP
donc ou sodiumnion on a des solutions
techniques et puis bon il y a des gens
qui ont travaillé depuis des dizaines
d'années sur du métal air sur du
lithiumer un certain nombre de choses
donc il y a des technologies évolutives
mais la date d'aujourd'hui et pour les
on est une industrie à cycle longue à la
date d'aujourd'hui pour les les 10 15
prochaines années le lithium les
batteries actuelles se seront la
meilleure solution pour 80% des usages
et la meilleure solution à notre sens
pour les compléments pour le véhicule
léger c'est l'association batterie pile
à combustible
après pour le véhicule lourd pour le
véhicule lourd il y a des usages qui
peuvent être plus simples et plus
intéressant et donc pour le véhicule
lourd on peut envisager de la combustion
à hydrogène
il y a beaucoup de gens qui travaillent
dessus actuellement vous avez même nous
un travail avec board Warner on a des
véhicules cardiologiques qui tournent en
Arabie Saoudite avec ces solutions là
mais globalement vu comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure grâce à l'opportunité et
l'ouverture de la norme c'est une
solution qui n'est pas zéro émission
mais quand tu fais des usages intensifs
tu vas pas en fait l'usage intensif tu
le fais pas en ville c'est un Barcelone
un Barcelone en bourse c'est pas 50 km
dans Paris entre guillemets donc et là
et là la notion de de polluants qui sont
déjà en très faibles quantité et moins
importante que des pollutions locales on
est dans des pollutions donc en fait il
y a des solutions il y a des solutions
qui interviennent dans l'ordre dans
l'ordre c'est ce que je disais pour des
véhicules neufs c'est batterie batterie
plus schulsell et pour d'autres usages
éventuellement carburant à hydrogène les
carburants synthétiques c'est l'étape
d'après alors techniquement si on est
capable de capturer le CO2 facilement
proprement et ainsi de suite c'est pas
une mauvaise solution parce que elle a
des avantages c'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est l'avantage de de stockage et du
transport si il y en a il faut quand
même avoir en tête c'est que cette
stratégie qu'on applique à nous à la
mobilité donc véhicule véhicules légers
camion ou bus vous l'appliquez pas aux
avions
parce qu'aujourd'hui un Airbus avec 500
places en électrique je crois pas que ça
existe donc les premiers qui ont besoin
de carburant synthétique embarqué
sécurisé donc liquide probablement plus
que gaz peut-être pas sûr pour les
petits avions c'est des solutions avec
des piles à 700 bars mais c'est pour
probablement les aéronautique qui sera
le premier tireur en fait dans la
mobilité de ce type de solution alors
après c'est la quantité est-ce qu'on
aura des quantités suffisantes et il
faut savoir comme pour faire quand vous
gardez le cycle pour faire de de
des solutions de carburant alternatif
c'est quand même complexe et la
meilleure
situation géographique pour les faire
faut avoir accès à de l'énergie
renouvelable faut avoir accès à de les
colises à proximité de l'énergie
renouvelable et beaucoup d'eau
il faut capable de stocker il faut
capable de le transporter vous arrivez
vite à une conclusion que vous n'êtes
pas loin de l'Arabie
donc après il faut se poser la question
où on le fait
donc on est on est quand même sur des
sujets qui sont qui sont il faut du
soleil et la meilleure solution pour le
faire c'est quand même du soleil des
fermes de photovoltaïques des
électrolyse idéalement ou si on savait
les croiser l'eau de mer électrolyse de
l'eau de mer et ainsi de suite capture
de CO2 donc on est on est sur des
solutions
qui sont qui sont à regarder mais qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas les meilleures
solutions qu'on a retenu
il faut savoir que notre groupe
industriels à l'objectif de regarder
toutes les solutions et après il choisit
la plus pertinente
mais la plus pertinente avec un axe
global en fait scientifique comme je
l'ai dit
on partage au pouvoir public c'était
quoi la question exactement
laquelle j'ai noté
partage vis-à-vis des pouvoirs publics
oui est-ce que
[Musique]
alors
c'était sur le fait que les
biocarburants et les fioules étaient la
solution pour décarboner le parc existe
on a du mal c'est vrai
c'est un message qu'on a eu du mal à
faire passer c'est un message moi que je
tiens depuis quelques années mais c'est
vrai que on est écouté mais pas entendu
je suis passé devant l'autre sens
entendu c'est un message qu'on a du mal
à passer parce que c'est beaucoup plus
facile de contrôler de contrôler les
ventes de normaliser les ventes de
normaliser c'est pas facilité comme j'ai
dit c'est beaucoup plus facile de
mesurer le CO2 si vous disiez faut que
je fasse un bilan Nox ammoniaque méthane
sur chacun des véhicules avant de les
mettre sur la route c'est un peu plus
compliqué donc on est on est on est sur
cette logique là et on n'a pas été on
n'a pas été entendu après pourtant on
l'a amené donc moi j'ai participé comme
beaucoup d'entre vous peut-être aux
assises des mobilités à la Convention
citoyenne la dernièrement la feuille de
route de décarbonation et maintenant
Marc anthur et du signalé on est en
train de réécrire un nouveau contrat de
stratégie filière comme à la demande du
Conseil national de l'industrie
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est qui
est spécifié et répété régulièrement
et donc il est
logique en fait quand vous c'est ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure notre parc
qui aujourd'hui majoritairement diesel
encore essence et très faiblement
électrique va l'être encore comme ça
pendant des dizaines d'années on parle
de 10 ans si vous regardez normalement
même si on tient tous nos objectifs de
vente qu'on a fixé en 2030 c'est à dire
70% de des ventes électrifiées en 2030
le parc en 2033 encore simplement donc
20% de véhicules électrifiés et donc 80%
de véhicules anciens thermique
donc en 2040 vous en aurez encore en
2050 en fait aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'on dit en moyenne une une véhicule à
une courbe de casse qu'on appelle une
courbe de casse autour de 15 ans mais
c'est une courbe de Gauss il y a des
voitures qui je suis un mauvais élève
j'ai encore une voiture diesel moi qui
est de 2002 il y a des voitures qui
qu'on garde plus de 20 ans
tu m'as fait le taf allez elle est en
province
donc en fait il y a des voitures qui
durent donc le parc actuel sur une
voiture que vous fabriquez que vous
vendez aujourd'hui certaines vont
exister encore en 2040 c'est ça qu'il
faut avoir l'esprit et donc la meilleure
façon si on veut réellement agir vite
sur sur l'impact
du réchauffement climatique il faut
s'occuper de ces voitures là on les a et
quand on parle de volume c'est une
question que vous aviez posé je pense
dans votre question les volumes
nécessaires c'est ce que j'ai dit les
volumes des du reste qui ne sera pas
électrique entre 2035 et 2050 et
tellement faible que les gens qui
doivent investir donc les pétroliers qui
doivent investir dans des solutions
alternatives de carburant
on dévolue le parc on le connaît on le
voit il est là donc ils ont déjà les
volumes nécessaires pour faire leur
bilan économique ils peuvent il faut pas
il faut pas qu'il nous disent comme je
l'ai entendu et je fais beaucoup
d'interventions beaucoup de tables
rondes mais il faut pas qu'il nous
disent moi j'attende savoir combien il
restera de voiture thermique pour savoir
si j'ai investi il investit pas pour les
voitures qu'on va vendre il investit
pour les voitures qui roulent et donc
ils savent ce qui roule encore et donc
là il y a de la pression à faire
il y a eu un mauvais
une émission sur total il y a pas
longtemps là je crois qu'il y a deux
jours ainsi de suite mais il y a
nécessité de de convaincre en fait
l'ensemble de nos acteurs et de
l'écosystème qu'il faut s'occuper du
parc donc je pense honnêtement beaucoup
ce sont exprimés je pense que je sais
pas j'étais pas présentation précédente
mais je pense que ou Nicolas ou de Bigot
ou Mark morue et ce problème de parc
mais on l'a on l'a souvent évoqué on a
été peu entendu
alors pour l'analyse cycle de vie
pour l'analyse cycle de vie
nous on est toujours favorables le
problème de l'analyse cycle de vie c'est
que dans nos choix industriels on se
donne les moyens de de définir ça donc
on a on a des moyens de calcul donc vous
savez sûrement que on est un groupement
scientifique qui s'appelle le GSM
maintenant ancien groupement
scientifique moteur mais s'appelle le
groupement scientifique électromobilité
qui regroupe l'IFPEN Renault et
stellantis et et dans ces et Aramco on a
besoin on est on se donne les moyens de
définir un certain nombre de modèles de
telle façon à en fonction de différents
scénarios parce que même si
j'ai souvent eu une image de prospective
automobile depuis 40 ans
personne ne connaît la vérité
donc au sens ça on serait déjà
donc on utilise des scénarios moi si on
me demande comment comment quels sera le
pourcentage dans le micro-ondes
probablement autour de 70% par exemple
de véhicules électrifiés donc 50 % sous
les électriques mais en fait c'est à
plus ou moins 20 % ce genre de choses
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est à chez
stépantis à 22 % on pense pouvoir passer
rapidement à des volumes beaucoup plus
importants mais on n'est pas à l'abri
d'aléa et un certain nombre de choses
donc on regarde différents scénarios et
on a des scénarios de mix donc on a on a
des modèles qu'on tourne avec
avant le ce qu'on appelait le bip
maintenant BDO qu'on fait tourner depuis
2009 avec des investissements c'est des
modèles gigantesques l'industrie
automobile a investi des dizaines de
millions d'euros depuis 2009 pour pour
avoir ces modèles qui tournent en
permanence qui permet d'avoir des
des visions prospectives et différents
scénarios et qui permettent d'établir
notre stratégie et avec l'IFPEN et
Renault on a transformé cette ces
éléments là en complétant l'information
avec des modèles mathématiques qui nous
permettent de donner l'impact et le coût
carbone en fait de l'ensemble de ces
scénarios là et regarder quel est le
meilleur scénario qu'on fait sur
l'ensemble de la cycle de vie en prenant
en compte la problématique des matières
en prenant en compte l'extraction en
prenant en compte un certain nombre de
sujets mais on le prend on le prend en
compte de façon significative on est
capable de dire voilà ce qu'on fait et
avec les pétroliers on regarde quel est
la réalité de la décarbonation de leur
carburant à chacune des étapes de de
cette trajectoire c'est en 2000 en 2025
comment on saura qu'elle sera quand on
mettra un carburant quel sera sa
contribution carbone en usage un certain
nombre de choses donc nous pour nos
choix indus triels on utilise ce sujet
là alors je fais attention parce que
j'ai fait une erreur que je suis
reproche à tout le monde quand on parle
d'analyse cycle de vie en fait là on a
parlé que du carbone on parle de carbone
full print
et quand on parle d'analyse cycle de vie
il faut savoir que l'analyse c'est que
le lit c'est une démarche multicritère
que normalement on dit on a une approche
analyse cycle de vie on regarde c'est
vrai le réchauffement climatique et les
gaz à effet de serre on regarde aussi la
consommation d'eau on regarde des
acidité on regarde les matériaux si on
en a assez si on en a pas assez on
regarde plein de choses et avec le JRC
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
en Europe on a défini 16 critères qui
sont en fait si on prend dans l'analyse
qu'il devine le retraitement des déchets
vous imaginez bien que les différents
types d'énergie ont pas les mêmes
caractéristiques
l'énergie nucléaire est certes des
carbonées un peu avoir sur d'autres
critères des inconvénients mais c'est la
même chose pour pour tout type de choses
en fait on s'aperçoit il y a il y a
aucun
et ça serait c'est malheureux à dire
mais il y a aucun sujet ou vecteur
énergétique qui respecte tout le spectre
ça marche après c'est c'est une synthèse
avec on dit il y a du poids pour chacun
des éléments on prend un certain nombre
de sujets mais sur l'extraction du
lithium les gens parlent de lithium on
va mettre de batterie on met du lithium
mais l'extraction du lithium a pas du
tout le même impact si vous êtes en
salar et vous avez vu en Chili vous
savez qu'on a sur l'impact sur l'eau sur
le Chili vous avez désertifié 100 km
autour de vos producteurs de lithium et
les Chiliens ils peuvent plus
ils peuvent plus planter un certain
nombre de choses si vous raisonnez en ce
qu'on appelle en Hard Rock sur les roses
dures avec de l'extraction vous avez des
consommations pour d'énergie pour
nécessiter ces trucs qui sont
différentes si vous raisonnez en
production de lithium en géothermie vous
avez en Alsace ou autre pareil donc là
la vision analyse cycle de vie et
impacte sur l'environnement de
différentes extractions en fait on va
pas dire c'est extraction du lithium
c'est trop général en fait localement
elles sont tous des impacts et donc il
faut qu'on prenne en compte tous ces
impacts là donc tout industriel on
essaye d'avoir la vision la plus
exhaustive qui nous oriente dans nos
axes stratégiques sachant que le cap qui
nous est donné c'est ce que je dis le
rôle d'un Président c'est de donner un
cap donc le cap qui est donné par Carlos
Tavares c'est net 0 2038 et donc on
regarde en fait tous nos choix
d'investissement et de et de production
en fonction de ce sujet là après à titre
à titre personnel très difficile à
réglementer un indices de vie ça va être
ça va être très très difficile
il faut le prendre en compte et puis
comme vous le savez
comme vous le savez c'est c'est une
c'est une démarche une méthodologie qui
est très facile à utiliser à posteriori
parce que vous devez prendre tout en
compte le transport donc un tout ou sont
fabriqués les pièces ou sont ou extraite
la matière tout de suite et donc en
prospective vous êtes un capable vous
prenez des hypothèses c'est des
hypothèses mais aujourd'hui c'est plus
facile de dire quand vous avez une un
véhicule qui est fabriqué à tel endroit
de remonter la chaîne entre guillemets
et d'expliquer la traçabilité de cette
chaîne là encore que c'est pas facile
parce que c'est vraiment un sujet ça
s'appelle le digital pour le passeport
qu'on doit mettre en place on a besoin
de traçabilité de l'ensemble de la
chaîne de la chaîne de valeur mais on
est capable de le faire à partir du
moment où on connaît en prospective
si vous si vous fabriquez une voiture à
un endroit donné mais que la pièce elle
vient de 1000 km c'est pas c'est pas
forcément bon quand vous regardez les
chemins ça ferait ça fait peur déjà ce
que vous regardez voyage les matériaux
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure un matériel
qui est produit
aux République du Congo il prend l'avion
il va en Chine parce qu'ils vont faire
du raffinage en Chine après il repart je
sais pas où parce qu'ils vont faire les
cames et les pré-cames je sais pas où et
ainsi de suite vous regardez il y a fait
le tour de la terre il y a des ONG qui
ont dû calculer qui ont dit que ça fait
plusieurs fois le tour de la terre mais
c'est une réalité c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a réellement la
méthode analyse cycle de vie est
beaucoup plus adaptée à un process connu
et maîtrisé
est-ce que ça répond à la question
écoutez vous êtes généreux en tout cas
dans les explications merci beaucoup
on a beaucoup appris moi je relève quand
même bien l'intervention de Carlos
Tavares votre président que j'avais vu
et écoutez élu sur le fait que et
j'avais nous avons rencontré ici le
président puyanais de Total que disant
que surtout n'abandonnez jamais le
moteur thermique avec des carburants des
carbonées
ce moteur thermique reste essentiel
c'est ce qui nous avait dit donc et
Carlos Tavares dit le tout électrique
attention
il faut peut-être pas voilà et moi ce
qui m'intéressait dans votre première
démarche c'est de considérer que il faut
être tenir compte des usages c'est vrai
on pourra pas avoir une énergie unique
pour tout voilà et
j'aurais aimé mais je n'ai pas dû
répondre aujourd'hui mais peut-être vous
envoyer une note sur votre analyse sur
les énergies consommées pour les
énergies produites
économiquement j'attends avec les
externalités positives et négatives
parce qu'on peut tout mettre dedans mais
voilà du champ à la roue au réservoir
moi je pense que ce sera intéressant
d'avoir votre analyse là dessus si vous
pouviez nous l'envoyer voilà moi j'ai
pas d'autres questions vous avez été
tout à fait très complet puis on pourra
venir vers vous et si vous pensez utile
de nous envoyer des documents de le
faire bien volontiers pour que l'on
puisse que notre rapporteur puisse avoir
tous ces éléments
on vit dans un monde compliqué
et je trouve que votre groupe je viens
de le regarder sur internet que
j'ignorais un petit peu et d'une
complexité extraordinaire avec un
chiffre d'affaires fabuleux
aussi compétitif que les Chinois ou pas
demain alors au niveau au niveau mondial
un point un groupe constantisme à la
limite peut-être
c'est un groupe global c'est à dire
on a un peu moins de 300 000 personnes
je crois et mais étalé sur 171 pays ou
nationalités donc nous nos raisonnements
ils sont pas c'est pas c'est pas une
plaque contre une autre la pérennité de
notre activité c'est d'être le moins
sensible possible en fait aux aléas
géopolitiques et donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on soit partout et les sociétés
qui résistent dans le monde automobile
comme je vous avais compris que j'ai
beaucoup j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec aussi d'autres d'autres
constructeurs
il y a plusieurs choses qui qui
m'interpellait c'est
qui disait toujours
il faut pas qu'on reste un seul européen
il faut qu'on soit un groupe mondial des
marchionner qui lui disait il n'y a pas
de constructeur automobile qui
survivront s'ils produisent moins de 6
millions de voitures par an
et même si c'est caraquetual ces
chiffres là et cette stratégie là elle
reste vrai le fait si vous regardez les
résultats de ces lentilles ce que vous
avez relevé et salué et c'est vrai c'est
quand même aussi grâce au fait qu'on
vende à la fois
aux États-Unis au Brésil en Europe c'est
pas l'Europe qui a fait gagner le
maximum d'argent cette année
au groupe c'est les États-Unis et à une
grande partie du résultat se fait donc
la santé du groupe industriel et qui
permet de garder des emplois en France
aussi parce qu'on a dû savoir faire en
France ainsi de suite est lié au fait
qu'on soit global et qu'on a un
raisonnement global
merci je vous répondrai une question
aussi les batteries on est propriétaire
des batteries quand on achète une
voiture et ça durée de vie c'est quand
même parce que fut un temps où il y
avait des batteries qui étaient
échangeables
c'est terminé ça oui non le problème du
des batteries interchangeables vous
parlez au ce qu'on appelle le swap
déjà en infrastructure ça demande des
infrastructures c'est une batterie ça
coûte ça pèse très lourd c'est un
minimum 300 kg donc c'est c'est quelque
chose et tout ça ça ne marche en fait
que si il y a de la standardisation
à partir du moment on est dans un monde
libéral et compétitif
je veux dire la réalité il faut faudrait
qu'on raisonne tout ce collectivement
beaucoup plus autour du bien commun si
vous regardez on parlez tout à l'heure
de la recherche de batterie la recharge
de batterie pendant longtemps moi j'ai
encore
je peux vous le montrer c'est en direct
j'ai encore un nombre de cartes
important pour pouvoir me charger
partout
il y a que l'affir qui vient de sortir
simplement cette année qui impose que
toutes les recharges de batterie à venir
soit compatible de la carte bleue on
vient de le décider qu'en 2023 Renault a
lancé la Zoé en 2011 je crois 2012
donc je veux dire par là c'est que le
bien collectif passe par la
normalisation
il y a un certain nombre de choses qu'il
faut traiter et donc on parlait
d'écosystèmes en fait c'est vrai que les
écosystèmes la politique d'énergie que
j'ai évoquée c'est pas les industriels
qui vont l'apprendre il faut l'imposer
la politique infrastructurale elle
implique aussi un maillage de territoire
un certain nombre de choses et ainsi de
suite donc les solutions que vous avez
envisagées qui ont été envisagées
sur les batteries donc de changer des
batteries ou d'avoir des modules de
batterie interchangeables
comme ces solutions de recharge vous
avez des tas de changer de recherche il
y a des gens qui font tomber la prise et
qui se prologuent automatiquement il y
en a qui amène de l'induction un certain
nombre de choses s'il y a pas de
standard ça marche pas parce qu'il faut
que toutes les voitures soient
compatibles au même sujet et là comme on
est dans un monde compétitif à chacun
prend sa solution technique donc dans ce
dans ce monde là actuellement libéral et
compétitif
les grandes évolutions qui sont très
impactantes et très intrusives sur les
architectures et sur les infrastructures
ont du mal à déboucher donc ces
solutions là ont été abandonnées sauf
dans le cas ou de des usages qui sont
individuels c'est-à-dire si une
entreprise fait du pire toupie
donc c'est le cas par exemple de
certaines personnes avec leur chariot
élévateur un chariot élévateur qui reste
dans un building et qui doit marcher 20
heures une des solutions c'est de
changer la batterie au bout de 8 heures
et d'en mettre une autre c'est une
solution donc ça marche quand c'est en
cercle fermé donc ce qu'on appelle en
flot de captive ça ne marche pas
malheureusement
en général pour le public merci merci
infiniment
merci de ce temps que consacré pour le
Sénat et pour le rapporteur merci